MARKUS KLUTE: Let's
come back to 8.701.
So in the previous
video, we talked
about higher-order
diagrams and we
looked at how we can
classify those contributions
to the total matrix element.
We didn't do any of
the calculations,
or we didn't calculate the
Feynman diagram itself.
And I'm not actually planning
to do this in the lecture.
What we want to do
here is investigate
one of the features, a very
important features of having
those higher-order corrections.
So if we look at this
higher-order diagram here,
one of the specific
ones where we
have a self correction,
self energy correction
to the propagator C here.
We find this loop
here in the middle.
And if you were to-- and we
have all the tools at hand
to actually do the
calculation-- if you
were to calculate the amplitude,
we find this term here.
So very good.
So let's investigate.
The first part is this
finite element here,
which we can rewrite
as q cubed times
a finite element dq times
all the angles which
we have to integrate around.
So we find this q cubed.
If you look at under
in this fraction here,
we find a q squared
times q squared.
And if you go to just
very large values of q,
that's the only
thing which remains.
So we have an integral, 1
over q to the fourth power,
times q to the third power.
And then we have to integrate
this from 0 to infinity.
So if you do this,
you know that this
results in a logarithmic term.
And if you have this
evaluated at infinite,
we find that it diverges.
So the result of the
integral is infinity.
That is a real problem.
If you calculate the
scattering process,
the result is
better not infinite.
The cross-section
shouldn't be infinite.
The lifetime shouldn't be 0.
So that is a real problem.
And that actually caused
this entire theory
to not really make much
progress for quite some time,
because you were not actually
able to calculate anything.
The solution is to
introduce a cutoff.
So what happens now if
we don't just [? jump ?]
to the integration
[INAUDIBLE],, but to some scale.
And so you introduce this
additional factor here
in the integral.
And you just calculate
the integral up
to a cutoff scale m.
And then you have
an additional term
you have to in principle
evaluate from m to infinite.
And you find that that
additional element is still
infinite.
You can evaluate
all the other parts.
And it turns out if you
are smart and introduce
the cutoff, the theory,
the calculation still
remain sensible, meaning
that they perform fine
under Lorentz transformation.
All the physics intuition
we have is fine.
You just have the
issue that still there
is a contribution to this
integral, which is infinite.
It turns out now by miracle
that you can redefine, re-scale,
or re-normalize the physical
objects in your calculation
such that it appears that there
is a correction to your masses
or a correction
to your couplings.
So what you find
then is that there
is a component which is
your physical value, which
is a bare mass and the bare
coupling, your coupling
constant, plus some correction.
There's still a problem
that those corrections
at infinite scale are infinite.
However, when we
do experiments, we
are performing them
at a specific scale.
And so this problem of if
you go to really high scales,
things get out of hand, is
actually not a real problem
when you compare the theoretical
prediction with the experiment.
There's an interesting
feature here.
When you actually look in
the running or the evolution
of your coupling,
which is shown here,
the function of
energy that shows this
as a logarithm of
the energy, you
can do this for the
electromagnetic, for the weak,
and for strong interactions.
And note here that this is
an inverse of the coupling.
They all run.
They all are dependent
and have to be
evaluated at a specific scale.
But unfortunately at
very high mass scale,
they don't all appear to
converge in the same spot.
It is interesting to
know that if I introduce
new particles along
the scale here,
note that this is 10 to 10
GeV, this new particle will
change the behavior of the
running of the couplings.
The energy behavior
of the coupling
changes if I introduce
new couplings.
And you can already
understand this
because I would introduce
new diagrams which
contribute in this way.
And then those
result in a change
in the running behavior
of the [? plot. ?]
So one of the ideas
for new physics,
which we might discuss in
the very last lecture of this
class, is that by introducing
new particles along the way,
you are actually able to combine
all of the couplings involved--
here, electromagnetic,
weak, and strong--
at a specific and
specific scale,
and then have a combined,
unified theory describing
all of the physics we discuss
in nuclear and particle physics.
So that would be great.
That is new physics, and we
don't know if this is realized.
However, what is realized
in our calculations
is that the physical masses
and couplings we observe,
they are evaluated
at a specific scale.
And they do run as function of
a scale as shown in this plot
here.
We will look at this
very specifically
at the running of those
three interactions--
the electromagnetic, the
weak, and the strong.
And we can also
observe this when
we study the masses involved.
They're have to be evaluated
or are evaluated in experiments
at a specific scale.